[Musique]
je suis vraiment content de partager ce
moment ensemble
je crois qu'on est tous là ici et
maintenant pour une bonne raison
en tout cas moi là tout de suite je suis
exactement qui j'ose être et où je veux
l'être
vous êtes bon aujourd'hui je suis en
plein dans mon rêve je vis exactement la
vie que je rêvais de mener une bon sens
que ça fait du bien c'est pour ça que
j'ai tant de gratitude pour vous vous
les humains qui au quotidien font des
choses qui rendent ma vie encore plus
formidable alors du fond du coeur merci
merci merci merci mon rêve à moi c'est
de vivre pleinement mon expérience
humaine c'est d'avoir toujours le
sentiment d'être au bon endroit et au
bon nombre a priori mais j'y suis j'ai
aussi une condition particulière
j'ai le besoin viscéral devrait pour
quelque chose de plus grand que moi de
prendre soin de la planète et donc de
nous avec un grand n ai beaucoup d'amour
et c'est ce nous collectif qui donne du
sens à ma vie
au final je veux juste offrir le
meilleur de moi-même saisir les
opportunités quand elles se présentent
et m'épanouir pleinement
je suis en apprentissage perpétuelle je
me et les genoux dit oui alors je vous
explique un peu à quoi ressemble mon
quotidien et comment je fais du bien à
la planète tout en typhon en ce moment
je viens jouer la campagne dans un petit
village et je donne naissance à un lieu
de vie sur un terrain que je loue à la
mairie c'est un morceau de notre planète
sur lequel je cultive toutes les
possibilités et où on dessine l'avenir
ensemble car ouais je crois vraiment que
le meilleur est à venir les amis bon ça
demande beaucoup de travail il faut
nourrir les plantes le sol les animaux
les humains planter récolter transformer
réparer éduquer
bref tout un tas de trucs qui prend
énormément de temps dans la journée le
truc c'est que je suis aussi un homme
moderne
j'aime passer du temps sur internet
faire des vidéos créés écrire m'éduquer
me balader en famille bref qui fait ma
racine la créativité m'est absolument
crucial ça met de la couleur dans mon
coeur je dirais même que c'est le
terroir de mon existence
et puis je vis aussi dans une rivalité
économique où j'ai des frais des
dépenses et un avenir assuré
je dois donc trouver un moyen de générer
de l'abondance alors comment fait-on
pour combiner tout ça comment vit-on son
rêve ici et maintenant
la première chose à retenir c'est que je
crois que c'est possible
en fait je crois que tout est possible
sauf coutumes et la gare comme le disait
les indiens pour moi il n'y a pas
vraiment de problème il n'y a que des
opportunités à saisir
j'ai d'ailleurs l'intime conviction que
tous les problèmes attendent des gens
qui se disent enfin oui je vous dis ça
parce que c'est à coups de huy que j'ai
ouvert le champ des possibles ce qui a
marché le plus pour moi c'est l'art de
multiplier les fonctions c'est parvenir
à faire un maximum de choses en
dépensant le moins d'énergie possible
tout en prenant beaucoup de plaisir
alors ce tedx et baye laye pour vous
pour nous j'espère bien vous avez chaud
p23 technique des ninjas pour rien pour
vous dire encore plus oui attention
mode d'emploi je me lève à laon le
soleil j'active mon véhicule terrestre
je me fais un petit café à emporter et
c'est hyper nana alia des cas ces
machines en salue les poules salue les
chefs vous pompe tout salut qu'aux comme
tout bon
ah oui j'ai oublié de vous dire j'emmène
tout mes animaux au boulot même coco le
cochon est ensemble on part glander en
forêt car ouais alors que je bois mon
café dans mon transat en lisant des
livres écrits par des gens comme vous et
bien coco irlande
il mange des gens les poules gratuit le
sol et les chèvres entretiennent les que
les chemins communaux nourrir les
animaux chaque jeu sort alors ma caméra
et j'en profite pour partager ma passion
pour la permaculture
salut les amis c'est baber et bla bla
bla bla bla bla bla bla bla j'observe je
médite bref je passe un moment
privilégié avec moi même temps personnel
et créatif jack et puisque je suis déjà
sur place et que j'ai un peu de temps
libre
j'en profite pour incarner ma plus belle
croyances je crois en effet que l'humain
peut être un agent de construction
massive je tue nous pouvons ajouter de
la vie et de la fertilité
partout où nous passons alors gp si et
amplifie le déjà existants je grève d un
fruitier dans les haies sauvages je
tresse les ronces pour créer des niches
écologiques et au passage quand tout un
tas de fruits pour replanter les vergers
de demain au même moment ma tribu animal
transforme tout ce qu'elle mange en
matière organique entre kaka quoi et ça
c'est de la nourriture pour le sol
ensemble on dynamise le vivant balade
matinale petit déjeuner et l'entretien
de la planète jake j'entre au bercail et
je m'assois de mon ordinateur pour pau
diffuser mes nouveaux biens bien je
réponds aux questions des apprentis
jardiniers et je lis les témoignages
ultra touchant de ceux et celles qui se
sont dit oui à chaque fois qu'il veut
sur internet j'ai l'impression que le
monde va mieux ces dix heures du matin
et j'ai déjà rayer toute ma liste de
choses à faire
j'ai donc tout le loisir de cultiver le
meilleur de mon humanité
vous vous rappelez demain ma vision et
mon besoin donner du sens à mon
existence
cette croyance ancré en moi qu'on peut
vivre ensemble et collaborer pour le
bénéfice de tous et bien en écologie ça
s'appelle la symbiose mutualistes c'est
quand deux êtres vivants s'associent
pour rendre leur vie encore plus
formidable
j'adore j'adhère et surtout je crois
qu'on peut mieux faire
alors je passe le reste de ma journée à
entrer en symbiose avec le vivant
j'appelle cette pratique le corps à
corps et ouais c'est pour moi un acte
volontaire souliers verts et
évolutionnaire je suis au service de
notre planète partager et puis un jour
j'ai une épiphanie j'ai réalisé que si
je voulais avoir un impact positif sur
la vie des frictions d'un problème à
résoudre
alors bonne nouvelle les problèmes on a
à la pelle et il n'y a plus qu'à
démultiplier les fonctions de nos
solutions
pour ma part j'ai réalisé que il y avait
de moins en moins de biodiversité dans
les campagnes la population vieillit les
jeunes vont chercher leur bonheur et
leur légumes dans les villes les plus
fermés écoles et sont arrachés au profit
des grandes cultures les produits
chimiques infiltrent les cours d'eau et
il ya de moins en moins d'habitat pour
les animaux on assiste à une dégradation
progressive de nos campagnes c'est aussi
très facile de montrer du doigt ce qui
ne marche pas le truc c'est qu'à chaque
fois que je monte tu dois y en a trois
qui reviennent vers moi et qu'il me dise
et toi bavard qu'est ce que tu fais pour
changer ça alors puisque je peux mettre
en mots cette décadence
je peux certainement lui apporter de la
résilience j'ai donc commencé par
conserver et préserver la nature
puis je me suis dit que je pouvais faire
mieux amplement mieux je peut aggraver
casse c'est le contraire de dégrader
quand on a grade
on encourage le vivant on augmente la
fertilité et on enrichit la biodiversité
en clair on accélère les processus
naturels je veux savoir que les
écosystèmes se régénère tout seul et à
leur rythme
quand on les laisse tranquilles le truc
c'est que moi je suis un peu pressés et
surtout j'ai de l'hyper créativité à
partager alors comme il me reste dix
heures par jour et bien autant les
mettre au profit de plus le monde
le truc c'est que je ne peux pas ni ne
veux pas faire ça tout seul moi je suis
pas un super héros après tout sauf un
oeil aux yeux de ma fille mycélium bien
entendu par contre je sais cultivé et
collaborer alors je laisse les autres
être aspiré puis inspirez faut savoir
qu'il ya deux façons de guider un groupe
sont les pousse dans un sens ce sont les
laisse nous suivre alors moi je vais
dans ma direction et qui sait me suivent
c'est donc en famille qu'on transforme
un ancien champ agricole en jardingue
ouais c'est un mot que j'ai inventé
j'aggrave aussi la langue française
c'est un jardin jungle un jardin gle on
appelle ça une forêt comestibles en
permaculture
je ne pouvais pas choisir entre vivre à
la campagne dans la jungle
alors j'ai fait les deux en même temps
notre succès vient du fait que tout le
monde est libre d'exprimer son talent
son entièreté est quelque chose de très
important
son essence et même si ça semble un peu
chaotique au début on finit toujours par
s'accorder les plantes grimpe les unes
sur les autres
les insectes trouvent leur bonheur dans
les fleurs les oiseaux pour les
générations de demain et les humains ne
s'offusque plus des mollusques tout le
monde à sa place
mais mademoiselle la limace car c'est
tous ensemble qu'on ne donne naissance à
cette jeune comestibles et c'est là que
la magie de la synergie agissante en
parlant de synergies et se tait dès que
c'est exactement ça on fait un corps à
corps au final c'est grâce à vous aux
organisateurs aux techniciens au coach
et au speaker que tout est possible on
vit ce moment ensemble ici et maintenant
et c'est ça que j'appelle le co qui
fâchent bon il faut coquillages
forcément je vous parle de mes amis les
plantes elles sont fascinantes et quand
on les connaît on n'a plus qu'à jouer y
construire ensemble par exemple
à force de blindés en forêt j'ai réalisé
que quand un homme tombé au sol aucune
branche cassée il faut tout de même une
connexion racines et bien toutes les
branches latérales se redresser pour
devenir à leur tour des arbres donc une
branche habilement plier équivaut à
plein de nouveau un potentiel à toi d'en
faire ce que tu veux dans nos régions il
ya aussi plein d'essence d'un que tu
peux taille et sculpté par exemple quand
tu coupes un gendarme au ras du sol
il repart plus vigoureusement et renvoie
un thème nouveau trou après par un
dragon anthologique si tu veux je peux
aussi couper une branche et la replanter
directement dans le sol et ça fait un
arbre sans parler des milliers de
graines qui partent en voyage dans
l'espoir de trouver un petit coin de
paradis
bref multiplier le végétal devient un
jeu d'enfant fascine et c'est le même
mécanisme au potager si je trouve ça
aussi excitant c'est parce qu'à force
d'étudier la biologie j'ai compris que
les plantes consommer du dioxyde de
carbone pour grandir vous avez tous
entendu parler de l'excès de co2 dans
l'atmosphère et des problèmes qui en
découlent dans aucun s'il ya un surplus
de co2 à nous de le fluidifier de le
mettre en mouvement en cycle de le re
sic les et nous pouvons faire ça
ensemble
donc à chaque fois que je cultive une
plante j mobilise du carbone et je
dépollue un peu plus la planète
et oui c'est possible et puis vous avez
compris la suite écologique à présent à
chaque fois que j'ajoute une plante
j'offre le gîte et le couvert un tas de
bestioles qui vont ajouter encore plus
de richesse à mon jardin gle et ce aussi
bien à la surface que dans les
profondeurs du sol grâce aux racines
j'agis donc sur un plan horizontal et
vertical
bon en vrai de vrai chaque être vivant
qui entrent sur ce terrain est
naturellement et passivement mis au
travail
tout le monde a du boulot chez nous on
collabore tous en kiff en onco kif et
oui je crois vraiment qu'on menait
toujours et tous gagnants à travailler
avec le vivant et maintenant le clou du
spectacle c'est l'alchimie du compost à
ce que je quitte mon compost pour
simplifier c'est une sorte d'estomac
vivant que je cultive dans un coin du
jardin je transforme tout mais bêcher
semer animaux et même ceux de mes
voisins en énergie vitale pour le sol
jeudi déchaîné j'aurais pu dire
déjections surplus ou même ressource
donc grâce au compost
je transforme les ordures en or pur et
les excédents en fertilisants et ça
c'est de la bombe organique pour les
végétaux gestion et valorisation des
poubelles tchèque
donc si vous avez bien suivi plus je
cultive mon jardin en plus je stocke du
carbone plus je dépolluer plus + jeu
nous fait du bien
enfin c'est ce que je crois de tout mon
être d'ailleurs le plus gratifiant dans
tout ça c'est le bien-être que je
ressens depuis que je vis et que
j'incarne mes croyances comme si c'était
un échange symbiotique avec la planète
et que j'ai troqué mon talent pour une
conscience libre et libérée je me sens
utile et valorisées comme en compost je
kiffe de plus en plus qui je deviens au
quotidien eh ouais la gradation est un
mouvement vertueux sur tous les plans
bon je crois aussi
et quand même que je peux mieux faire le
truc je sais aussi que plus on est à
croire en une idée plus elle s'enrichit
alors autant rallier un maximum de gens
toi monsieur mais tous points toi qui
sera le prochain à planter un jardin
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que nous
sommes bientôt 4 milliards d'humains
connecter à internet et je peux entrer
en communication avec eux depuis mon
canapé et en un clic
alors la question se pose qu'est ce que
je vais leur dire qu'est ce que je vais
nous dira alors moi j'ai décidé de vous
montrer comment germaniser mes croyances
et mes actions
ça fait plus de dix ans que je mets des
vidéos sur youtube c'est mon dont mon
cadeau et mon service pour la communauté
je montre mes techniques de ninja et mes
abonnés sont inspire pour à leur tour
initier leurs projets plantez des l'un
des jardins et qui fait leurs racines
quand on fait le compte ça en fait du
carbone stocké dans le sol merci les
jardiniers n'ont au final c'est génial
de bosser pour la planète
c'est un super patron gp en fruits et en
légumes en nombre en parement en bois de
chauffe en beauté et bien plus encore je
troque du soin planétaire pour de
l'abondance nourricière et au début
j'avais peur peur d'oser temps de me
lancer peur que ça ne marche pas peur
d'être seule et puis j'ai appris à
composter mais peur car j'ai compris que
c'était justement elle qui me montrer le
chemin je me suis totalement lancé en
totale confiance
je me suis donné la permission de vivre
mon kiff je me suis dit oui et
aujourd'hui ça coule de source
j'ai lâché mes doutes pour tenir mes
rêves car oui je pense que tous nos
rêves sont possibles quand on lâche
prise
car une fois qu'on tient plus rien eh
bien on peut construire avec nos deux
mains pour conclure j'aimerais insister
sur le fait qu'avec un morceau de
planètes en location je génère de
l'abondance pour moi ma famille mes
voisins ma campagne et indirectement
pour des milliers de gens car oui pour
moi l'abondance c'est à voir
perpétuellement assez pour faire ce que
je dois faire
en fait la plupart d'entre nous
connaissent déjà répondant ce parfois
même sans s'en rendre compte
l'abondance c'est à voir
perpétuellement assez pour faire ce que
vous devez faire c'est tout à fait
possible d'être emplis de matériel et de
se sentir vide ou de ne rien avoir du
tout et se sentir complet je vous le
répète une dernière fois l'abondance et
avoir perpétuellement assez pour faire
ce que vous devez faire alors
simplifions nous la vie mais justement
simplifier sa vie ne veut pas dire
nécessairement avoir moins c'est pour
moi l'art d'avoir mieux c'est être
totalement conscient de ce qu'on a déjà
et que le peu qu'on a peut-être mis à
contribution de tous car ensemble
eh bien on a tous alors ceci est une
invitation les amis peu importe qui vous
êtes jeu c'est fondamentalement est
biologiquement que vous êtes unique au
monde
y en a pas deux comme toi tu es comme un
flocon de neige
tu es une pièce du puzzle et le jour où
tu ajoutera-t-on oui à notre oeuvre
collective alors le monde nous
ressemblera et nous rassemblera soit le
oui que tu veux voir dans le monde
tant qu'il y aura des rêveurs en action
il y aura des solutions
moi j'y crois merci
[Applaudissements]